the new reality is like we don't even
want you having this other thought we
want you completely on board like you
can't say negative things about the
Democratic Party because that's false
balance I think all that's very very
dangerous over the past 20 years few
journalists have tossed more hand
grenades or built more of a reputation
for themselves than Matt Taibbi who
covers politics and culture for Rolling
Stone when not writing best-selling
books such as Griff topia insane clown
president and most recently I can't
breathe
a powerful account of the death of Eric
garner with Fame comes controversy of
course and Taibbi is no stranger to that
a 2005 piece for the defunct free weekly
the New York press was titled the 52
funniest things about the upcoming death
of the Pope
it was denounced by everyone from
Hillary Clinton to Matt Drudge to
Michael Bloomberg to that paragon of
good taste Anthony Weiner and with the
publication of I can't breathe last fall
Taibbi has come under attack in a wide
array of places ranging from Twitter to
the Washington Post for work that
critics say is flat-out misogynistic and
sexist things are described I'm saying
they did not happen Taibbi is published
at least two apologies about his past
work but the firestorm is barely abated
the reason I like Matt so much he says
that his support for Bernie Sanders
throughout the 2016 election is what's
really motivating these attacks on him
and that they are even leading to
something approaching a media blackout
for his book on Eric garner and I'm just
very proud that he's with us tonight in
Burlington let's welcome back baby we're
gonna talk about all of this and about
issues on which progressives and
libertarians overlap in powerful if
always uneasy ways let's start with I
can't breathe which is you know
immensely moving powerful and
comprehensively reported account of the
the various social cultural legal and
law enforcement forces that led to the
you know that left Eric garner dead at
the hands of the police in July 2014
remind us of who Eric garner was and why
he was being hassled by the police on
the day he died Eric garner was
this really interesting guy he was a an
ex-con who was known in a neighborhood
in Staten Island not far from here
a place called Tompkinsville he was a
little bit older he was 43 years old he
had a number of children and he was for
a living selling untaxed cigarettes on
the street obviously we have the highest
consumption taxes and this is part of
the Bloomberg right legacy if I hate
smoking when I raise taxes and and
garner was part of a large group of
people that were bringing lower or
untaxed cigarettes from Virginia from
Indian reservations exactly the
Bloomberg serve single-handedly created
this whole subculture of arbitrators
based basically who would go to these
other places buy you know cigarettes for
four or five dollars a pack put them in
the backs of cars driving off to New
York and then they would sell them for
eight or nine dollars a pack where if
you buy them in a store here there would
be 13 bucks and that's what Garner was
doing he was one of and then sometimes
he would break him down this is
something my father who grew up in New
York during the Depression he used to
talk about Lucy's like we're you it's
illegal to sell cigarettes individually
but garner and people like him would
break down a pack because you could make
even more money margin slightly and and
incidentally the practice of selling
loose is you can find it pretty much
everywhere in the city yeah
you go to any subway station you'll find
a Lucy dealer but also if you go to
expensive nightclubs in New York you'll
find people selling rides there's always
a person around the bar but it's and
it's amazing that you know the
prohibition on you know that
prohibitionist don't think people if
people want a product they're not going
to come around with come up with a way
to get exactly yeah so Garner selling
loose cigarettes it's against the law he
has been arrested multiple times I mean
he's he's both been beaten and robbed by
other Street criminals but he's been
arrested multiple times for this right
yeah and obviously this all takes place
within the the sort of nexus of the
broken windows policing strategy which
is this thing this idea that was created
here in New York City which
is basically you focus on minor crime
you you go after people who jump
turnstiles you ride bicycles the wrong
way down the street you drink out of a
open container it's catching somebody
graffiti and graffiti is like you know
visible crime there's a whole disorder
right yeah the visible signs of
disorders what they call quality-of-life
arrests so in the context of that the
whole idea is if you if you go after
enough of those people it will
eventually cause a decrease in serious
crime because people will be less likely
to go outside with a gun they'll be
afraid of being caught for something
stupid the practical result of all this
is just that they had enormous numbers
of summons is written for really really
minor offenses and people like Eric
garner who did things that weren't even
misdemeanors in many cases like selling
a Lucy doesn't even rise to the level of
a misdemeanor
he should get a ticket get something
like that it is homage yeah exactly
but they be they become very very
visible targets and he had been he was a
big guy he was like 350 pounds and then
whenever the police wanted to hassle
somebody or get her get it their numbers
up they would go after this guy and
let's talk a little bit about Garner and
then go back to the origins of broken
windows because part of the I think one
of the most interesting points of parts
of the book is that you actually look at
what broken windows and you talk to one
of the main theoreticians of it and what
it becomes but so Garner is and and this
is something it's also fascinating this
was caught on video by a guy you know
Randy yeah who is what a jailed name
yeah and he was arrested originally
basically for filming the police doing
this but this is where the line I can't
breathe
and garner before the police taken into
custody he's like hey man you know why
are you hassling me leave me alone right
so what did the cops actually do to
garner the timeline of what happened
that day is really strange they from
what we can piece together somebody from
the precinct who is of higher rank like
a lieutenant had driven by the spot
seeing garner on a corner and then
instructed this sort of Crime Squad
detectives to go back and pick him up
the problem was garner wasn't actually
selling cigarettes that day and this was
one of the weird things that I found out
when I first started researching the
book I talked to almost everybody who
was there that day did like a
minute-by-minute you know a timeline he
had an argument with somebody in the
street because they thought he had been
snitching the night before then he'd
felt unwell he went into a bathroom he
came out he broke up a fight he's
leaning up against the wall catching his
breath when the police approach him now
here's where you get into the whole
problem of how policing works and why it
can sometimes have tragic consequences
when when bureaucracies are set up the
wrong way you know I talked to a bunch
of cops and basically they told me if
your superior officer if your lieutenant
tells you to go clean a corner you can't
come back to him and say well we just
moved the guy around the block you
needed a number right you need to show
him that you did something which for
these two detectives meant getting Eric
garner physically into a car arrested
and charged with something and so here's
Eric garner this 350-pound man who's
already had a long history with the
police who's leaning up against the wall
who's in terrible health or
deteriorating health deteriorating
health right he's got asthma he's got
diabetes he's just broken up a fight and
he's wondering why the police didn't do
anything about that and they tell him
he's got to go police station and you
can see in the video that it just
doesn't register in his head like what
why me why now and he refuses and
there's this paradox like what do you do
these guys have a bureaucratic
imperative they've got to bring him to
the station but he's thinking I didn't
do anything and I'm not gonna go and so
this results in this decision I think
it's a fateful decision that they made
which was that they were gonna they were
gonna bring him in no matter what and
instead of letting it go they put their
hands on him then it's this melee ensues
and they use a chokehold which is
forbidden technique and he dies and and
he's laying on the ground for something
like eight minutes before they offer any
kind of medical assistance yeah they
thought he was faking it first there was
a store owner he sort of fell into a
beauty beauty salon yeah and the owner
that stores that are asked one of the
police officers will why aren't you
doing anything and they're like yeah
he'll be fine yeah and this is a if
you've covered a lot of these these
stories and I know that reason does
cover a lot of these stories this is a
consistent feature of a lot of these
cases is the sort of medical and
attention the ambulance that either
comes a little bit too late you know the
old Public Enemy song 911 one is it joke
it you know it actually is true it turns
out you know that the the there often
lacks they leave the person unattended
for a long period of time and you know
who knows what it would have happened
because garner technically didn't die
until he was in the ambulance about
twenty minutes later I think so that's
another key aspect of the story how
important is it that this was captured
on video use your cell phone and and how
is that changing I mean cuz the book and
this is something that you know
obviously you know on a certain level I
think to the extent that the reason
audience knows you it's because you're
you know saying that Goldman Sachs is
you know a multi-tentacled right octopus
sucking the lifeblood out of humans the
Koch brothers or [ __ ] all of this kind
of stuff but for people who are
interested in criminal justice reform
sure I mean it's it you know how
important is it that we're now seeing
police brutality not you know it is an
eyewitness accounts it's actual video
account
yeah I think it's it's critically
important I mean I that that entire year
that really began with the garner
incident but there was a secession of
them right there was pretty pretty
pretty Michael Brown there was the young
woman in Texas you know who was knocked
down by police and like the Rodney King
beating you know been back in the 90s
but all of these had a demystifying
effect I think largely on upscale white
voters and in cities who just don't see
this stuff you know I mean I think if
you live in in the pink houses here in
East New York or if you live in Harlem
you've seen all this stuff before it's
no surprise to you but but if if you're
living another kind of environment
seeing it and seeing how it all plays
out and seeing how the interactions
actually go not just in snippets but in
it but in huge long scenes I think
that's critically important I think it
was important because otherwise you know
legends grow around these things and and
the the police very quickly turn around
the narrative as they as they've done
countless times in the past and it
becomes something else let's talk about
stop and frisk and work back from that
towards broken windows because you know
part of the book and I mean the garner
arrest isn't quite stop-and-frisk but
it's it's related to it and stop and
frisk was a policy that was in place for
years in New York which essentially
allowed the police to say you know I got
a hunch about somebody right and so I'm
gonna stop them and I'm gonna frisk them
and you know what was stop and frisk and
you I mean you post some like
unbelievable numbers about how many
stops were being made and who was being
stopped right yeah stop and frisk grew
out of a case in Cleveland Ohio I think
it was 1961 I think was the original
incident the Supreme Court case didn't
happen until 68 it was called Ohio v
Terry and basically what it said they
were the incident was a police officer
who saw some people on the street that
he he felt were acting suspiciously part
of his suspicion was just that it was
white people hanging out with black
culture and what I mean you're either
in a doo-wop group or you're buying
drugs right exactly and so he he the
question was whether it was legitimate
for a police officer just on the basis
of a hunch to go and start a questioning
people and then be in this incident he
ultimately ended up patting people down
finding weapons on on some of the people
in the group and that left us with this
standard that we have that survives till
today which says that police can stop
and question anybody that they have a
quote-unquote articulable suspicion are
in about to commit a crime and one of
the ironies that you point out in the
book is that that decision was made by
Earl Warren right who you know any of us
who remember Dirty Harry I mean or
Warren is the you know the [ __ ] judge
who you know who like criminals go free
right but he would by the end of the his
era he was feeling the heat so he
actually was like oh yeah you know
because we're now I think the way you
talk about it he he essentially says
like we're not really gonna stop the
police from doing this anyway so we
might as well make it usable basically
yeah it's there's a very strange passage
in in the opinion of Ohio v Terry and
you're absolutely right judge Warren had
been under a lot of criticism from sort
of Beltway Society that he had through
like Martha Miranda law through Matt V
Ohio which you know sort of prevented
the you know the unlawful searches and
seizures and all that everybody thought
these were coddling criminals laws and
Warren wanted to give police a tool
maybe perhaps to restore his reputation
with with that crowd and in the decision
what he's basically says is there's
nothing really that we can do it that's
at the Supreme Court level to stop
police abuse but we can do something to
fight crime and so that very strange
passage with that he gives police this
extraordinary tool which now puts
probable cause in the heads of police
officers and it's entirely subjective I
mean there's no the standard isn't a
real standard it's just if you think
something's up right then you go ahead
put your hands and
mean to I guess to give Warren who you
know is forever burning in hell for in
turn you know pushing to in turn
Japanese during a Japanese Americans
during World War two
I mean there was a tripling of crime
going on right from the yeah I mean in
the post-war era it and every city
people thought you know this was it but
yeah but it leads to this and then in
stop and frisk there were early moments
in New York City where stop and frisk
was pulled back right or there was a
civilian review board that was put into
place to kind of make sure the police
weren't abusing this but that had no
real effect on it well for a long a long
period of time stop and frisk they
didn't even have a word for it
originally they just called him Terry
stops for a long time and that's what
they're called in most cities and there
there was really just one squad that
used this technique and they were a
special unit of detectives who would go
around the city and sort of just sort of
randomly put people up against the wall
and search them it wasn't until the late
80s and early 90s when this new idea of
let's let's use all the available legal
tools that we have to start doing
something about the crime rate in New
York because New York had this terrible
reputation if you remember if you watch
movies like quick-change well that's
almost the end of them but yeah clear
Taking of Pelham one two three you
mentioned warriors even escape from New
York which is kind of a fantastic but
from about 1968 maybe feel about I don't
you know whenever quick change that
every movie about New York was what a
[ __ ] it was and we gotta get the
[ __ ] out yeah you know like a Neil Simon
comedy was about this yeah right right
exactly and you can't even get out of
the city because it's so dysfunction and
and so they you know they first the
first thing they did was they they went
after the graffiti in the subways which
was a very visible symbol of how the
things had sort of gotten out of the
control of the authorities and and it
took them a long time to do this there
was this really actually long
interesting subterranean war between the
the graffiti artists and and the police
they finally got the last dirty subway
car off line then they started
implementing what they called stop
question and frisk on the street and
originally in the conception of the
people who design these ideas it was
supposed to be used very selectively it
was supposed to engender a feeling of
safety among civilians but wasn't
supposed to be particularly aggressive
what ended up happening was under the
leadership of Bill Bratton who is again
the commissioner right they created this
very stats heavy regime of in which
officers were encouraged to do as many
of these stops as possible and by the
time the mid-2000s rolled around they
were stopping in this city about 600,000
people a year and somewhere between 80
and 90 percent of those people were
black and Hispanic and the city was more
than half white right so there was
clearly an issue that had developed over
well this is what you know and this is
you know coming out of the black lives
matter moment movement and out of
Ferguson and whatnot this is there's a
plausible case there that it's you know
it merely being a black man in
particular Hispanic man is a criminal
act in New York I mean that that's the
feeling among the minority community for
sure they have a very good reason for
thinking that because one of the key
theories and behind the whole broken
windows movement is this idea that
people who are afraid are already victim
of crime right that was the sort of
progenitor of broken windows is very
interesting guy named George Kelling I
think it's kind of a tragic figure in a
lot of ways he had this idea that people
if you are afraid to go outside if
you're elderly you don't want to go to
the store you are already victimized
problem is a lot of people in New York
City are afraid of black people so it's
like a syllogism right if you people who
are afraid or already victims a lot of
people here are afraid of black people
there for being black is a crime and
that's kind of the way this worked out
and well and you know and let's talk
about cowling a bit who I believe ended
his career
as a criminology professor a professor
at Rutgers he's still around
mm-hmm but shortly after Garner's death
he told the New York Times that while
stop and frisk had clearly been abused
by police he said the fact that blacks
and Hispanics were arrested at higher
rates made sense it's not the police's
fault he said it's not White's that are
terrorizing those neighborhoods it's
African Americans how is he wrong about
that because this is the the
conservative complaint about like how
you stop you know stop and frisk you'd
do that like of course they're gonna
stop blacks because blacks come in all
the crimes right okay
well there's a couple of things I would
say and and and then we'll come back to
cowling because you I mean he's
absolutely not a racist I mean he you
know he is a tragic figure yeah I think
yeah I think his his theories were they
went in a direction that he didn't get
back I would have two responses to that
number one is I think if he went to Wall
Street and you and you started
aggressively throwing everybody up
against the the wall and going through
pockets and tearing open briefcases
you'd find an enormous number of drug
cases the statistics say that 71% of
illegal drug use in New York City is
committed involves white people so a lot
of that is selective I mean if I've been
living in the city since 2003 and I've
never been stopped randomly on the
student never had you are probably
carrying right now one of the ironies of
stop and frisk too is that pot you know
possession of pot for instance had been
decriminalized but showing it in public
was a crime right and so cops would say
hey you know would you show us what's in
your pockets and so if a guy complies
and has a joint he's committed a crime
right yeah I mean it gets really kind of
weird really quickly ya know that that
was that was something I learned about
in a for a previous book that I was
writing that you know we have
theoretically decriminalized marijuana
in New York City and yet we have 50
thousand arrests a year for possession
how does that work right I mean it works
because in exactly the manner you
described you police will stop somebody
they empty their pockets and suddenly
you know the private consumption or
of a legal amount of marijuana becomes
openly displaying it in public and
that's different that's a crime and so
so that's one thing and the other thing
I would say is the answer that of course
there are more stops in black and
Hispanic neighborhoods and that's where
the crime is is not a defense against
the accusation that you're profiling
people right like the the charge in all
these cases is like you can't stop
somebody on the basis of whether or not
whether they're black or what they're or
what their age is or whatever it is just
to say that it works and it's logical is
not a defense against profiling it's
actually an excuse for profiling so I
would you know I would say two things I
would say if they if they employed the
same techniques that they employ then
these other neighborhoods they would
find plenty of crime and to you know
that's unfortunately that actually makes
the case for the FIR the lawyers who you
know who were taking on stop the FIR and
since stop and frisk because it has been
a you know it's been officially stopped
and reduced substantially crime is still
low so everywhere in the country because
you know there has been a massive
decline in violent crime and virtually
all forms of crime since the mid 90s
that nobody was expecting what are the
co-authors of the breadth and window
Sarah James Keith Wilson was I mean he
he was one of the sources for Hillary
Clinton talking about the rise of super
predators in the mid 90s every
criminologist almost was predicting a
massive and ongoing crime wave from a
90s peak and it just bottomed out so
clearly we're not quite understanding
what's causing crime to go up or down
sure and and that drop took place in
cities that employed these strategies
and cities that didn't employ these
strategies so it you know if you talk to
criminologist about that she'll it's
funny you'll actually get a lot of
people who will say oh I have no idea
you know I mean which is pretty rare for
an academic dean you know that's an
aside the most interesting theory about
that and part of it and I know some
people particularly people who are even
filming this interview our big believers
in cops that and you know there's a
strong case to be made for that but one
of the most novel arguments I've read
that consumer goods the type of stuff
that was common you know that people
would steal for like they would break
into a window you know in a car because
they saw something stuff has become so
cheap you know you you you don't you
know there's less need to that impulses
God that makes sense I don't know and
then of course aging you know
demographics because most crime tends to
be committed by younger people as we get
older right better but yeah I mean
there's there's a real discussion about
why are we in such a crime-free
Europe sure and then of course there's a
there's a very kind of key question that
you have to ask if we have this
continually declining crime rate why is
the rate of incarceration going up so
fast well yeah in some ways it's late
it's leveled off yeah yeah yeah yeah and
of course again the you know you get
these arguments where it's like well
that's why crime went down because even
if those people weren't criminals
you know we swept up a bunch of
criminals in but then you get to that
question of what kind of country are we
living and right yeah exactly I mean the
numbers are just so easy talk a little
bit more about culling because he in an
early 80s article with James Q Wilson
the sociologist and criminologists in
the Atlantic that's that's what broken
windows came from you you talked
extensively with keling how was he
dismayed by what he was talking about
originally you know how it kind of
transformed over time I felt killing
fascinating because the origin of all
these theories came from an experience
that he had as an administrator of a
home for troubled youth in rural
Minnesota in the early 60s so race is
not an issue here at all right this is
just he's he's like basically the warden
of a mental health facility and he sees
that the people who are running the
place are allowing the kids to do all
kinds of crazy things if they start
carrying the tiles out of the ceiling
they just let him do it if they break
glass they leave the glass in the floor
and Kelly's observation was let's clean
up the surroundings a little bit and
maybe that will turn the temperature
down on some of the neuroses you know
but every
was like strictly Freudian they wanted
to observe everybody yeah I mean it's
amazing sections of the book cause he's
like Pat O'Brien and angels with dirty
faces or you know dead end they Humphrey
Bogart movie if like he's kind of the
kind hearted priest who just starts
calling [ __ ] and saying like you
know you got to clean up after yourself
exactly that you got to do that and it
had good effect yeah I mean it's it's
simple logical it would be something
that like any parent would do right like
if you if somebody's acting out you set
boundaries for them set rules for them
you know don't allow them to be messy
all the time I mean these are these
aren't like difficult theories to
understand but out of this group grew
this idea that when people see disorder
if it gives them psychological
permission to act out more right and
this this germinated in his mind over
and over again and he began to think
about it in terms of what its
applications possibly might be for
helping prevent crime and you know as
there was other research in this you
know like the the Philip Zimbardo at
Stanford did some research on this and
Lombardo is most famous for the Stanford
Prison Experiment which is you talk
about getting the most mileage out of a
two-week experiment that only had a few
days but in this you talk about it in
the book where he took two cars I think
that were you know clearly not
functioning and he put one in a in what
was it the Bronx or in a Boston
neighborhood brought a crime
neighborhood yeah and it was
skeletonized within you know hours but
then he put it in a kind of nice
neighborhood in Palo Alto yeah and
nobody touched it and then but then he
went back and broke a window and then
instantly yeah yeah yeah and what he he
used a very strange term to describe the
people who did the skeletonizing of the
car and that but basically the idea was
until people saw the disorder they felt
like they didn't have permission to go
to go destroy the car so this becomes
the basis of this policing strategy
which is you know it may not it may not
actually decrease crime but if they're
we don't see people drinking
openly in the middle of a median strip
if we don't see people riding their bike
the wrong way down a sidewalk or peeing
in an alley like maybe they'll be less
something less disorderly people feel
less afraid you know that was certainly
one of the early conclusions but even
even Kelling understood early on that
there was potential for this to go in a
bad direction like he he remembered
talking to people in Southie in Boston
you know my hometown and and basically
their idea of disorder was like letting
black people in the neighborhood right
and so this idea of a Fuhrman of lis
imposing order or trying to create order
it had a subjective meaning you it could
result in all kinds of eventualities and
you were leaving it in the hands of
individual police who probably would
have different ideas about that from
city to city and from precinct to
precinct and and they they even wrote
about that in the original broken
windows article and they said we we
don't have a solution for this we don't
know how to prevent it but it could be a
problem right and then obviously turned
into what yeah it made many ways so wait
where does Kellen come down ultimately
on you know and I mean he told the time
shortly after Garner's death he was like
you know I'm not sure that should
selling Blue Cigarettes be you know the
type of thing that you clean up or not
and where where do you come down on that
because it is you know there is a
certain logic to it and we do want to
have you know and I say this is a
libertarian where I think you know
cigarettes should be legal and Russia
bail you know smoke them wherever
anybody won't let you and sell them by
the half I don't care you know but do
you need to impose order you know and I
think it was Rand Paul might have been
the and he wasn't he was widely made fun
of like MSNBC for saying something like
you know nobody should die for selling
loose cigarettes right and it's kind of
like yeah everybody can agree with that
but then if you start working backwards
where do you end up it's certainly not
an easy thing to unravel but I think
where I came down in this ultimately was
and obviously I'm a white journalist
night I didn't grow up in this world
they didn't have a bad experience of
with the police growing up I didn't have
grandparents telling me about what they
had been through but in you know in
black communities they do and they'll
tell you that the kinds of laws that
were developed to make these policies
possible are very similar to the laws
that existed in Jim Crow and you know
after the Civil War the vagrancy laws
basically if you can arrest somebody for
obstructing pedestrian traffic or you
know refusal to obey a lawful police
order which can mean anything right like
you know we want you to stand over there
you don't do it fast enough you create
an enormous possibility for mischief and
and misfortune when it just becomes too
easy to arrest people and the the other
problem with this policy that as far as
I can see is one that's if you have a a
policy that's based on creating a
statistically high number of contacts
between police and the population over
things that aren't that important a
percentage of those are gonna go
sideways right I mean I think if you
think about a lot of the incidents that
were famous in the recent years they
weren't over very much you know they
were they weren't him they were they
weren't like you know shootouts at the
OK Corral over something very meaningful
but this isn't the semi-nice Liberation
Army yeah you know exchanging ten
thousand rounds with the LAPD over a
parked car yeah exactly I've read
studies that have read about studies
that have shown that actually in each
individual police contact blacks and
whites are not more likely to have a bad
outcome
but blacks have many more contact
exactly yeah I mean so that's part of
what's going on right now Eric Garner's
daughter Erica and you write very
movingly about her in the book she
recently I mean just very recently died
and you eulogized her she became a force
for reform in the wake of her father's
death and you wrote a you eulogized her
just recently saying she tried
everything she held rally led marches
spoke constantly on television and radio
met with officials from the city and the
federal
pushing not just for results in her
father's case but for wider reforms like
the creation of an independent
prosecutor to investigate police
killings there were some successes but
mostly what she heard were promises that
went unfulfilled what are the what are
the things that she accomplished and
what what is what is the most pressing
reform really going forward you think
well they did manage to successfully
Lobby
Governor Cuomo to temporarily create a
prosecutor who would look at police in
these cases they wanted to make that
permanent they didn't succeed in doing
that you know she was instrumental and
leading some of the protests in December
of that year in 2014 but by and large
she was very disappointed in a lot of
the outcomes I think the what she found
over time and this is something that I
wrote about in the book is that the
system is really designed to respond to
families in her situation really in just
one of two ways we either give them
money or we don't give them money beyond
that like sort of institutional fixes
finding out what happened with the you
know inside a grand jury room you know
federal civil rights cases they're there
they're fairly rare and she she wasn't
you know a lot of people said you know
as soon as they got the money they they
should have been happy with that the
money didn't mean anything to her she
was just as mad the day after I remember
as she was the day before so she was
just a really interesting person very
different I expected something totally
different I expected her to sort of
insist that her father be portrayed in
this kind of heroic light and she was
completely different from that she
wanted things to be real and she had you
know high expectations for she thought
for herself I mean she she got a lot of
attention from politicians and in both
parties and that didn't impress her so
much she she sat down and she thought
about
what who she wanted to side with and why
and it was it she was just an
interesting person so you know over
criminalization of everyday life the war
on drugs sentencing reform cash bail
reform these are all issues where a good
chunk of progressives and libertarians
overlap a lot and it you know it's kind
of fascinating when you see uh you know
like somebody like Rand Paul and Cory
Booker in the Senate you know talking
about sentencing reform in a variety of
things cuz they don't seem to have much
else in common right um what do you
think are the best ways forward on these
kind of you know interesting ad hoc
overlaps like what what are what are the
best ways forward to actually produce
real change well I think one thing
that's important is to make people aware
of their kind of shared views on some of
these things I think there are a lot of
people who don't realize that they agree
with each other about a lot of these
things all the things you mentioned are
absolutely true I think there are a lot
of Americans who would agree with the
cash bail reform system don't like the
idea of private prison profiteering I
mean there's you know my next question
was what are the roadblocks to coalition
building and I'm about to show one I'd
say oh you know enough with the private
prisons they represent ten percent we're
at the end of the population the problem
are police you are not policing prison
guard Union Public Roads right but I
agree I mean that yeah I guess actually
talking about issues rather than talking
about tribal affiliation well I mean
this is the whole problem with American
politics in general is that you know
it's it's become it's it's become this
just giant gigantic ongoing screwing
match and we just don't have dialogue
about things and it's totally
non-productive it generates an enormous
amount of rancor and anxiety on issues
where things could get done like and
licinus in this space where I think
particularly in the area of things like
the drug war whether I think there's
widespread agreement about about not the
ridiculousness well the Attorney General
as we're talking you know has just come
out with
thing saying like hey states don't even
think about right you know govern along
like as if marijuana isn't a federal
crime right yeah yeah we might just be
protecting institutional turf right you
know and yeah but in terms of the
population I think people widely agree
about a lot of the stuff and it would be
it would be great if we could talk a
little bit more about the areas where we
agree you know things so you know
another place where there I think
there's a substantial overlap between
libertarians and not all but a lot of
progressives or liberals you know and I
realize there's meaningful distinctions
between you know kind of centrist
liberals leftist progressives but one
thing is an absolute defense of freedom
of speech or of heterodoxy maybe even a
better word like of you know independent
thinking you've expressed can see Ruiz
concerns to me privately that there's
something approaching what you called a
new anti speech movement on the left and
you know and part of it is you you've
experienced that that you're being
kicked out of a kind of liberal media
Club for for the crimes of not being a
good party Democrat for opposing Hillary
Clinton even after Rolling Stone
endorsed her and then you wrote a
counter endorsement of no Bernie is
really the guy that we should be backing
right you know for being skeptical the
idea that Russia is you know is calling
all the shots in America and even for
saying that economic anxiety is a real
thing I gotta check all the box yeah
let's let's talk about this you know
what are what are the signs for you what
are what are the signs that you've been
blackballed or that you're you're
getting squeezed on I mean it's not so
much about my case I know I understand
you know I've been through some stuff
this year a lot of it is stuff that I'm
angry about because I you know I was
accused of sexual harassment basically
by people who didn't look into the case
and I have the weirdest case of all
because I have there's no accuser
fortunately I think that's sort of
unraveling and but you know people are
going back through and reading some
stuff that from an old paper that I
wrote
co-wrote with a guy named mark games 20
years ago and that's sorta legitimate
for you know for people to go back and
reread you know earlier so this is the
Exile the moscow-based English language
Russian newspaper that yes which was a
an exercise in like absolute pure free
speech we were trying to like violence
on this you know it reminds me in many
ways and I gotta say I didn't
particularly care for it but of suck and
a couple of early websites like write
you I mean the whole point was to be as
grotesque as possible yes it was like
dark black humor to the extreme and and
this stuff there was a reexamination of
your exile stuff and some of your New
York press stuff when I can't breathe
came out right you know and it's it's
kind of interesting the Weinstein stuff
was happening me to came about do you
sense that your politics bother people
who think you should be a fall in line
you know Hillary Clinton supporter or
you know that the Democratic Party is is
the good thing and is that where I mean
is that what's motivating this XQ mning
of your corpus I think I'm just sort of
accidental collateral damage to a larger
thing that's going on yeah I started to
worry in the summer of 2016 right around
the time I guess that the primaries
ended and the conventions were happening
there started to be discussions within
the journalism business about maybe we
should rethink how we do our jobs all
right and the idea was that Donald Trump
was so bad that we had to rethink
balance objectivity and there started to
be this creation of all these terms that
that appear immune both sides is a
neonate arisen right like and if you got
one of these labels it was really bad
like you didn't want to be label to both
sides us and then there started to be
openly editorial is in some of the major
news organizations I think particularly
of a piece by Jim Rutenberg
the New York Times who said that you
know we have to rethink our jobs and one
of his points was that our new idea of
how we measure truth in journalism it
should be we should be true to the
judgment of history all right
which to me man let's get on board with
Hillary Clinton and help her winter
campaign and I want to be really clear
about this it's not because I like
Donald Trump or that I dislike Hillary
Clinton although you do I do I am NOT a
fan of Hitler right but the the issue
here for me is the disenfranchisement of
the press right like when when the press
jumps on board with a political party
when we essentially volunteer to become
an agent of a political party we're
giving up our institutional power like
we just we derive all of our power from
the perception at least that were
independent and so just sort of
willy-nilly saying we've got to help
this person get elected we've got to
stop this person from getting elected
everybody join in and you know let's all
be on the same team for me that's that's
almost like giving up and give it and
seeding our power and because what I had
seen in there on the Republican side
during the primary season was that when
outlets like the National Review tried
to write things about Trump they were
completely tuned out by by audiences
because audiences perceived all of these
outlets to be tools of the Republican
Party already because it for four
decades they've essentially I think had
men and and that's why I think the media
has to you know zag when everybody wants
them to Zig we have to make an effort to
even if it doesn't always make sense we
have to make an effort to kind of be on
the sidelines all right but it became
kind of de rigueur that journalism has
to be in service of something it has to
be and it has to have agency and it has
to have a political purpose that's very
specific and I think I thought that was
a very dangerous idea reason we write a
lot about
you know kind of the proliferation of
choices and options and you know yeah
Bernie Sanders famously and I think
really stupidly denounced in an early
interview I think was Jim with John
Harwood where it's like oh you know
there's like 36 flavors of deodorant and
there's you know two dozen types of
sneakers nobody needs that much choice
yeah I actually really dig choice I like
choice and but that politically you know
the the coalition's that form the
Republican Party and the Democratic
Party I mean these are these are things
that kind of came into their modern form
in the 70s those groups don't exist
anymore and it's you know but the
Democrats are saying no like if you have
to be a Hillary supporter like you can't
be there is no progressive caucus and
the Democratic Party anymore that's
worth a damn or fall in line when you
have to and the Republicans in way are
going through a more fascinating crack
up because Trump is not really a
Republican right he's clear like he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about the Republican
Party he cares about himself you know
how much of it is just that we have you
know that our political institutions
have not caught up to the variety of
political experience or political
expression that people want sure I mean
that's that's definitely part of it and
there's I think a new or loud would say
an enhanced hostility towards fringe
parties right I think one of the
consequences of Trump's election was
this idea that if you don't have a
serious chance of winning you should
never ever run right like somebody like
Jill Stein and I'm not talking to
somebody who voted for Gary Johnson
right but there we have unbelievable
outpouring of hostility from journalists
right about this like you you know not
only not only should they not have run
like they shouldn't have the right to
run right like it's it's morally wrong
to do this and to me like Trump Trump is
living proof that anybody could win
anybody can win right and and that
political parties you know they they're
often susceptible to challenges because
they they underperform you know and
and so I think it's the whole idea of
having coalition's of you know having a
green party that has its own set of
beliefs maybe votes Democratic and you
know who knows whatever it is that's
kind of gone out the window now the new
the new reality is like we don't even
want you having this other thought we
want you completely on board and and
along with that we want you to have a
whole set of ancillary beliefs like you
you can't say negative things about the
Democratic Party because that's false
balance right etc etc and I think all
that's very very dangerous it created
creates this idea that you know for me
it started with journalism being
directed toward a purpose then it
becomes humor has to be directed toward
a purpose right like you know Tina Fey
gets lamb basted for making a joke
that's not totally in the right
direction right like then it's you know
art has to be in a certain purpose and I
you know this is a radical idea and you
do you see it mostly emanating from the
left at this point in it and that as a
man of the left had that's got a bug you
I mean I think what's happening now I
think there's there's always been that
kind of instinct on the right well
conservatives not even hide it yeah
exactly it's completely out in the open
the whole idea of sort of disciplining
people with who have unorthodox beliefs
you know what you do you love the
terrorists you look you know it's that
that sort of thing but it's this is a
new technique on you know our our side
of the aisle and yeah it worries me a
lot because it's it's it's illiberal and
then you saw it's I know after
Charlottesville there there's this like
incredible letter from people within the
ACLU talking about how they shouldn't
have you know
done the case you know in support of
free speech rights and that that sort of
thing and that speech is now equated
with with racism and that's sort of like
when even the ACLU is is rethinking
these ideas it just gets back to the
idea for me that when people are scared
they start throwing their rights of
report it's the same thing that happened
in 9/11 like we can't afford to have
habeas corpus and do Constitution is not
a suicide pact yeah exactly if my guy
might lose right right right
so you know one of the things that and
and this is a phenomenal we touched on
it briefly but a phenomenal reversal in
contemporary American politics where
Democrats are now saying you know that
people you we have to be very afraid of
Russia the Republicans of all people are
Donald Trump and conservatives are like
you know come on Putin's not so bad
right
you obviously lived in in Russia you
were a super critic of the Yeltsin
regime it's just kind of incorruptible
and also Putin what is your sense like I
mean is is Putin a mastermind who you
know can it can reach 500 people on
Facebook with the shitty ad and like you
know it and and make Hillary come lose
or you know what what is the reality of
that threat to American democracy I
found this story very confusing from the
very beginning I've been more troubled
by the way it's been reported than I
have been by anything else you know
getting back to the idea that journalism
has to produce a political result a when
when I first voiced some concerns about
this story I got all sorts of letters
and tweets from people saying if you
were a real investigative journalist
you'd go out and find the proof right
right yeah which gotta be there yeah we
worked the other way around like we work
we work we follow the work owes and snot
and whatever it leads but you know I I
don't know I mean there's an old joke in
Russia about Gorbachev he gets up late
from work one day because he's hungover
or he goes to his limousine his drivers
hungover he throws him in the back gets
in the car starts to drive to the to
work gets pulled over by the police they
let him go
the cop goes back to the car and the
other cop says who was that and he says
I don't know but Gorbachev was his
driver and the the the joke is that in
Russia you never know who's in charge of
what like what's going on are things
being done are things being directed
from on high are there people
freelancing so they're like even
something like the hack of the DNC
emails or Podesta there's a huge range
of possibilities of what happened there
was it was it part of a larger plan was
it was it somebody at one agency trying
to outdo another agency like we don't
know we don't know the specifics of it
but narratives form before we had
concrete and it does seem in the current
moment all of the narratives are in the
service all of the Russia is evil
narratives are in the service of Hillary
didn't really lose because she was a
terrible candidate right yeah yeah I
mean that's that's certainly one way
that I look at it I think that the the
Russia story is definitely had utility
to the Democratic Party in the sense
that it's been a distraction from I
reckon that I thought was going to come
immediately after the election like how
could we possibly lose to this right
right I thought they were they would sit
down and immediately you know put their
heads together and say we have to
completely rethink what we're doing you
know recent political party autopsies
haven't gone well because the
Republicans did that right in 2012 and
then they COFF up Trump so that's right
that's right we need to reach out to
minorities we need to be younger
etcetera it's one of the sharpest
attacks you know and this is in the
specific the attacks on you really have
focused kind of coming out of the broad
base me to movement and you know the
Washington Post ran an article calling
attention to your work in the Exile you
know and and the Exile had articles you
know and I guess people debate whether
it was the satire or retro actively
defined a satire but about sex with
teenage underage prostitutes rape
workplace sexual harassment you've
denied that such accounts were factual
and paste magazine actually did one of
those rare things where they called up
two of the people who were in a story
and they both said now you know Matt
Taibbi was a gentleman you're in a
relationship with one of them and it was
like this is all [ __ ] but then in a
1999 exile piece and I guess what I want
to talk about now is in the broader
context of me - you know what has
changed since you know 1999 or 2000 but
you wrote in a piece progress hasn't
caused men to back away even slightly
from viewing women purely as sex objects
sure we'll let you pay for half of the
sushi and we've learned to avoid staring
at your asses as blatantly as our
fathers and grandfathers did but that
doesn't mean we actually prefer to see
you dressed in painters pants and
sneakers or listen to you deconstruct
Incan folk tales no we actually prefer
Russian women who embrace the roles of
sex objects and that won't change no
matter how many times you insist you
don't end the you know Russian women and
then in your 2006 book about the 2004
election spanking the donkey you called
The Washington Post reporter Karen
Tumulty
Manesh a pre-op version of Dave Barry
and a female impersonator so those are
something like the bad things right
right yeah and then you in one of the
Facebook apologies you read you say I
have regrets about many of the editorial
decisions made in those years I wish I
could go back to my younger self and say
what you were doing is wrong stupid and
hurtful to women so talk a little bit
about you know what's changed in you as
a person especially regarding your
depiction and treatment of women you
know in just the terms that you use but
also what's changed in society and why
and as you know are you comfortable with
those changes I mean I have to go for me
personally I originally had this idea
that I was an equal opportunity offender
I mean if you look at
the things that have written about men
over the years there's always a savage
physical description of pretty much
everybody yeah you're very much out of a
kind of rapid lazy nor trust very and
fizzy anomic right on that you you read
you you you read the values of the
person particularly if you dislike them
right into features yeah I mean it's
it's caricature it's it's a it's a way
you know it's a trick that you use to
try to get people to pay attention to
sometimes a more difficult subject so
for instance I really I spent eight
years writing about you know banking and
credit default swaps and you know people
will have their eyes will glaze over
unless you have a juicy description of
somebody or you yeah you have to
caricature eyes make characters for
people for years I operated under the
idea that it was okay to write the same
way about women that I wrote about men
and be as insulting and and caustic and
I think it it took a long while for you
know people talk they pulled me aside
and said things like look women have to
deal with being judged in their
appearance far more than men do it's a
it's a different set of parameters and
you know I'm embarrassed that it took me
as long as it did to come around on that
issue but but it did I and I the reason
that I did is purely had to do with like
I had this sort of fierce belief that
that writing had to be pure and like
separate from you know those kinds of
political ideas but I I think I was I
mean I was wrong I think ultimately and
society's changed in a lot of ways in
terms of its attitudes about a lot of
these things there are a lot of things
that that were considered ok you know
fodder for jokes that were acceptable
back in the 80s and 90s that would be
totally crazy today I mean you know if
you think about you know Sam Kinison
routines and you know Eddie some of any
Murphy's stuff like all of Eddie
Murphy's yeah there's a reason he hasn't
had a hit right of the clumps or dr.
Doolittle right yeah it's it's stunning
if you and I wouldn't recommend anybody
do this but if you watch episodes of
Three's Company which from the 80s and
they're still making like Tinkerbell
jokes that I guess at the time we're
funny or even kind of edgy right or now
you're like kind of what's going on what
do you think I mean is that how do you
how do you define or how do you how do
you distinguish between good evolution
of social mores where we're more
inclusive and less kind of douchey to
people and just like the worst kind of
political correctness where it's like
you know somebody in the corner can
always just be like that's not funny
that's right funny yeah it's it's tough
it's it's a difficult question I think
for me the dividing line is when the
requirement is not just that you avoid
certain kinds of things but that you
actively push forward a certain line of
thinking and that that be in your
writing that to me is is a huge
difference from you know we shouldn't
use the word [ __ ] anymore right like
it just hits the ear wrong now and it
should I think that might explain what
johnny Knoxville never made it out of
the ringer writing her it's been kind of
a tough slide for him yeah you've
alluded to this before like you wouldn't
yeah I mean you're not gonna let other
people off the hook for the stupid
things they wrote in the past so it's
kind of like turnabout is fair game and
I'm thinking I know you know like
journalists we always do this to the
people we want to kind of get under and
so Robert Byrd you know is always a
member of the KKK and you still here
that's the first thing that anybody
mentions about him who despises him Joe
Biden plagiarizes life story Hillary
Clinton lied about being under fire like
I mean so you're kind of stuck with this
yeah your and you're just gonna have to
kind of work through it right I mean the
only thing I can hope is that people you
know go back and look at the Exile and
and at what I mostly did it that they
have that job which was work actually
very similar to what I do today you know
I I spent a lot of time at that job
essentially doing a kind of
fact-checking work were you know
journalists they would say there's an
emerging middle class in Russia and then
I would go out and you know I would like
work as a bricklayer somewhere for a
couple of weeks or you know and find out
is there an emerging right now I did a
lot I mean I wrote probably a million
words worth of that stuff back factoring
and so can we also because one of the
stuff that gets most remembered from the
Exile of stuff like you know pasting
people with pies made out of horse yeah
is that yeah that is that's pretty much
in the past for Matt Taibbi absolutely
I'm 47 years old have three kids and I
mean and horse semen is very difficult
you know without and frisk well so I
mean I guess to finish up you know apart
from the validity regarding your
personal case and you know and you you
have a I think a pretty strong argument
against you or a case that you're you're
being singled out you know you wrote
some reprehensible things you know
that's in the past and you know I must
say for anybody you know as somebody
reading I can't breathe I mean it is not
a book that in any way is it does not
traffic in cheap stereotypes either of
you know the good people are the bad
people it's like a really spectacularly
live reported and and written book I
mean I have to agree and there are parts
of it that I don't fully agree with but
there's that but how dangerous and
widespread do you think the kind of like
the emerging anti left a anti speech
left is and what you know what what are
the best ways to kind of push back
against it not just from a progressive
perspective but you know more broadly
because it in in a world where we you
know everybody has their own printing
press that of reverse the AG Liebling
quote you know who said that
you know you only people have a free
press or ones who own them we all own a
printing press now how do we how do we
kind of valorize the idea of hetero acts
Petra knocks independent thinking
particularly in journalism yeah I don't
know I mean it's very difficult because
the the journalists are people they the
problem and some of them yeah
they go on Twitter and when you see
yourself described as a racist or a
traitor or a KGB spy or any of these
terms to get thrown around you know the
instant you cross certain lines now like
Twitter lets you know whether there are
real people or BOTS or whatever they are
like the the parameters of what
acceptable thought are within that world
are pretty clearly defined and they let
you know what subjects are okay to talk
about which ones are now I started
keeping a list in 2016 of things that
that apparently people didn't want me to
talk about but you have to be just
resist that and and be willing to take
the criticism and and not be afraid to
talk I mean I I know a lot of
journalists who are afraid to weigh in
for instance on the Russia story I know
people who are more prominent and famous
than me by met by significant degrees
and we're afraid to weigh in just
because they don't want to do what they
have a name and I can't but you know but
they so you're part of the problem I am
part of the problem but they you know
but there were it it's just it's become
a thing where nobody wants to deal with
what Glenn Greenwald goes through every
day on the on on Twitter right like he's
got a gazillion people out there telling
him that he's this that and the other
thing and it it becomes hard after a
while and and and it convinces people to
not to not weigh in with ideas and
that's just bad I mean it's it's it's a
negative idea uh for everybody to be all
on board and afraid to say something
different and I we used to sit really
celebrate the diversity of our
and our ideas even on the left I
remember just right outside the store
there was a march in 2004 against during
the Republican convention which was here
and they had flyers that told you to
dress differently to voice your opinions
on things differently to engage in
discussions like they act that was
actually an element of of the march was
to be different from everybody else and
we just have different values now and
it's weird and I don't know how I don't
know what the solution is but I think I
think you know we got to start talking
about it all right well we will leave it
there thank you so much Matt Taibbi
we've been talking with Matt Taibbi the
Rolling Stone writer and the author most
recently of a fantastic book about Eric
Garner's death called I can't breathe
thanks again thank you very much
for reason I'm Nicholas Lee
[Music]